in the year 1949 bill bladdy was an
undergraduate at Georgetown University
the oldest Jesuit school in the country
while in his religious class his
religious instructor told him a story
about a demonic possession and exorcism
of a fourteen-year-old boy now this
story was widely publicized on the front
page of the Washington Post and a number
of other newspapers and the story flatly
stated that there was a
fourteen-year-old boy in Silver Springs
Silver Spring Maryland who was possessed
by the devil and exorcised by a group of
priests in an Alexian Brothers Hospital
in st. Louis Missouri
bloody and I guess everyone in his class
felt that if this story was true if this
could possibly be true it would be
religious nirvana
and so he set out to try and get as much
information about it as he could and of
course the church would say nothing the
church would not and rightly so you know
to maintain the privacy of the family
they gave out in fact whenever they were
asked a lot of false incorrect
information they said that this happened
in Silver Spring Maryland it actually
happened in a smaller town nearby called
Cottage City Maryland but the church did
everything it could to protect the
family and the boy the boy was evidently
successfully exorcised and he then later
in life went to work for NASA and he
worked for NASA for 25 years and retired
owning a lot of
patents for his inventions the family
was Lutheran they weren't Catholic they
went to their Lutheran minister who said
we don't have anything to deal with this
young man's affliction so try the
Catholic Church which they did at the
Washington DC diocese now as I say
bloody couldn't get any of the facts so
he decided to write his novel as fiction
The Exorcist is a work of fiction
whether you believe in possession and
exorcism is totally up to you it has to
do with the mystery of faith
but none of us have any of these answers
none of us nobody no one who's ever
lived none of the greatest philosophers
who ever lived
know if there's a heaven or a hell or
God or angels and demons it is a matter
of your belief system or no belief
system but I think one of the reasons
you're here tonight is because we're all
curious about the possibility of the
supernatural I certainly was